so let's get right into it i'll start
with you ben uh since for my audience
you're more of a new face here tell us a
bit more about yourself your background
and really why you chose to pursue a
venture in the decentralized finance
space
you bet yeah it's great to meet you
thanks for taking the time to chat with
us
so my my background i'm actually a
recovering securities lawyer so i
practiced uh i practiced law for about
five or six years at the start of my
career um helping companies raise
capital go public um and and mostly in
the oil and gas sector so i was living
in calgary um and uh and then in 2016 i
decided to move to vancouver to get more
involved with technology companies and
and that's when i discovered bitcoin and
um yeah and then everything changed from
there basically
the rest of the rest is history yeah it
was uh yeah it was just kind of uh yeah
a a great great kind of uh turn of
events and and so uh you know being a
lawyer at that time i saw a lot what's
happening in the space um and so i got
involved with advising um some of the
first crypto projects in canada and and
the us and so there's some like super
interesting stuff going on at that time
and um
yeah and then from there just sort of
saw the potential of uh of of crypto and
and got out of uh legal practice and
more into um building products and uh
and really just trying to try to bring
more users into the space i think one of
the one of the things i noticed really
early on is
um it doesn't matter
when you get into crypto um
somebody's always going to be
like talking about oh i've been in this
space for you know you know two years or
three years or four years or five years
and it's kind of really i think it's
it's really uh it it can be a pretty
insular kind of uh space and and uh and
i think the you know whole purpose is is
really meant to be inclusive and and
like accessible to everyone so um yeah
i've just been like my my focus and
career in the crypto space has really
been trying to bring more bring more
users and people into the space
awesome so great strong background in
crypto uh and on that like in that vein
can you explain a bit more wonderfully
uh really what this new platform's about
because it's completely new especially
to my to my audience as well
yeah absolutely so it's so the the
decentralized finance or d5 area is
definitely the highest growth um sort of
space within d5 um and uh and we've seen
like over the last 18 months or so um uh
a lot of activity uh a lot of it's
focused around decentralized lending and
decentralized exchanges um but there's a
lot of different applications it's
really like people are excited about it
because it's it's it's the future of
finance it's um it's sort of everything
that you know that we could have you
know dreamed of back in 2016 and 17 for
for those of us that that were in the
space that time uh like a really great
application of smart contracts and um
more efficient you know faster
uh cheaper transactions in in a lot of
ways um but one of the things that we've
seen and i think for for any of your
audience that has played around on d5
will will be able to attest to is uh
it's it's it's overwhelming to go into
defy and try and figure out like you
know what the hell is going on so um we
we really looked at this from a
entry-level user's perspective how do we
simplify this as much as possible and
just lower the barrier to entry so it's
all about um you know simplifying and
creating better access to d5 so wonder
fi
um you know plugs into kind of the best
functionality that we see in d5 and that
we we think users should have access to
and then um and we really just
streamline that process for them
awesome so kevin i'm assuming the reason
why you're wanting to get involved more
in a decentralized finance by the way
defy is decentralized finance for anyone
who wasn't following that reason why you
wanted to get into that is most likely
just because this is such a new space
and really i saw online you were saying
that
prior to
uh higher levels of compliance and stuff
it was kind of harder for you to get
involved in the space so could you speak
a bit more about really what your
motives are right now about getting into
crypto while it's kind of booming and
well yeah i'll let you answer that for
sure right now it's true crypto is
booming there's no it's particularly
getting a remarkable amount of time in
social media in the press uh for good
and bad reasons i mean there seems to be
uh a desire by the popular press to
vilify the participants in crypto
and pit them against regulators all
around the world and that's simply not a
fact it's it's it's great you know fake
news but it's not not the reality
decentralized finance um
the potential of it is to make the
financial services industry far more
efficient and less costly to transact
and that's the baseline by which there's
so much interest in why certainly i'm
involved uh i but most of us that are
participants that are already involved
in financial services have no interest
in getting involved in crypto against
the regulator we need we want the
regulator to to regulate it like all the
other products and services that we're
involved in so that that's the overview
but let me give you a use case that i've
just lived through over the last year
that makes me highly interested in in
getting
much more involved in crypto and
decentralized finance we reduced our
holdings in commercial real estate over
the last 18 months in our operating
companies portfolio it was over a third
and now it's down to eight percent that
generated a lot of cash and
traditionally what we would do is go to
cash desks
that you know we work with and and look
to put that money to work in a short
duration
fashion we were offered 21 basis points
of interest 21 basis points in inflation
is currently around 2.1 percent so
effectively we are going to be losing 2
percent of the buying power of that cash
every 12 months
that is not acceptable and so that
forced us to go and look at alternatives
in the d5 space around the ideas of
stable coins that we could stake or lend
and and garner you know theoretical
interest rates of 3.8 to 5.2 based on 30
60 90 day contracts which is what we
attempted to do
now
when i say you know attempted to do this
we can't do that without being compliant
to our internal compliance our external
auditors and are reporting to regulators
it took me months to set that up almost
six months plus three new hires just to
get that done at an operating company
level so i could be compliant and i
could
structure this in a way that was
compliant now
it was incredibly hard to do so if you
think the average person that you know
that's why i invested in wonderful i'm
really interested in in creating an app
for people so if my daughter wanted to
put 14 000 to work in a staking program
she's not going to do what i went
through and she also has to be compliant
she also has to be able to report her
capital gains and her interest to the
tax authorities and the trouble with the
crypto space today is there is no
infrastructure for compliance and so
that's what wonderful is attempting to
do is to provide all of those services
make it easy to use consumerize it
commercialize it make it a platform
anybody can use and above all be
compliant with tax authorities
yeah so there's a couple things to
unpack there that my audience might need
some more context on first and foremost
could you explain a bit more the idea of
a stable coin and then also
the process of staking to incur interest
on those amounts because right now for
sure we're seeing a level of interest on
high interest savings accounts pretty
much is is null and the idea of putting
money into the equity markets right now
especially when people are trying to
save money is on a shorter term basis
isn't necessarily the the best option
for some of my audience members who have
asked me so yeah really how does that
work for staking and how can someone
uh ensure that they're going to like is
it
is the uh is someone insuring in
incurring interest on
their amount deposited or how does that
work like for stability in terms of
because there's so much volatility right
now in the crypto space and that's what
a lot of my audience members are weary
of and that's why they're staying out of
the crypto space
yeah and they should be i mean there's
nothing wrong with with scrutinizing and
i'm not telling anybody to put all their
money into crypto i certainly don't do
that
but i have increased my weightings and
i'm going to continue to increase um you
know i originally was had a target of
three percent in crypto and i think
we'll probably be close to seven percent
by the end of the year in the operating
company but having said all that let's
talk about stable coins the concept of a
stables coin is it just to build a a
coin that is backed by a stable currency
like the us dollar and that's what die
in the usdc does now remember these have
been very controversial of late because
the regulator
think about a money market fund that's a
regulated entity when you put your money
into a money market fund at a dollar
there's a bunch of instruments inside of
that that might be short-term uh
treasuries there might be other things
that the regulator looks at you have to
report on it but but
stable coins are not regulated yet the
same way and so this the regulator has
gotten very concerned about these
because they've grown from a very small
amount usdc is over 30 billion dollars
now and so there's lots of interest in
it and so you have to think of it that
way it's it's a it's a coin that
theoretically is backed by the us dollar
and that's why the regulator is taking
an active interest in it and you know
there's been a lot of controversy uh
around tether and
all of this is out there in the market
it's you know being debated out there
every day and so the idea and here's how
you stake it if you if you take 100 u.s
dollars and buy
um usdc with it you can then write a
contract for 30 60 90 days or longer
and
stake it or in other words lend it out
for
yield in usdc so maybe you're going to
make an annualized basis of five percent
paid back to you in usdc you can take
that usdc convert it back into us
dollars and that and that's what some
people are attempting to do
now i'm not telling you that's easy it
is not easy to do it's very complicated
the average person is never going to do
it and i talked about that earlier the
whole concept of of wonderful is to to
allow that's one use case
um
and the whole idea of decentralized
finance with wonderful is to allow you
to do that in an easy fashion that's
transparent and allows you to report
your taxes because when you make that
interest if you want to call it interest
of that five percent in usdc
that's something you have to report to
the regulator to the to the tax
authorities and you need reporting
standards to do that and that's what um
wonderful is attempting to do
awesome yeah so i looked over obviously
wonderful what uh the ucas are supposed
to be and some of the products that are
upcoming so so let's speak about some of
those quickly first of all
there will be a high interest savings
account so then maybe you can speak a
bit more about that so a user comes in
deposits let's say ten thousand dollars
what could they expect from that type of
account
yeah so really what we're doing is is
just you know again providing better
access to uh the the most high value
things we see within d5 and and then
also i should i should kind of clarify
and it's helpful for me to to kind of
hear where your users are at with crypto
and kind of what's keeping them out of
the space i i think that's that's like
super insightful um so what you know
what one of the things we're we're
really focused on is curating the
experience so we're keeping people away
from
a lot of the more experimental stuff
that's going on with efi some of the
more high risk
assets because i think if you read the
headlines you'll you know you'll see
like there's you know there's hacks that
are happening where uh you know customer
funds are being lost and um like you
know issues like that which are uh which
are are not great for the space but a
lot of that's happening on these really
experimental kind of uh protocols and so
there are other protocols which are
audited tested they've had billions of
dollars of transaction volume go through
them like uh like compound for instance
which is um is one of the the most
popular lending um protocols and and so
what we're doing is we're steering users
towards um towards those avenues because
we see them as being more suitable for
somebody that's um that's entering the
space the for for the first time so um
on the sort of savings like earn product
that that we have it's really uh
enabling people to uh
to earn on their assets through compound
um and uh and so like for
for again for users that are new to this
space
some might not even be comfortable with
the volatility of like uh eth or bitcoin
or some other crypto assets and so
having having something like usdc uh you
you you asked about the concept of a
stablecoin it's you know a crypto asset
but it's tied to the value of the us
dollar so the us dollar goes up
you know or down it just tracks that
it's not something that's uh going to
change with the price of bitcoin so like
we see that yeah so go ahead so like
someone's not going to deposit ten
thousand dollars just for more
clarification to my audience here
someone wouldn't deposit ten thousand
dollars and then that ten thousand
dollars is highly exposed to the
fluctuations of of bitcoin for example
exactly it's it's not at all and it's
just it's it's just tied to the value of
the us dollar and um and so uh usdc was
created by by circle which is um a
company that's been doing a lot of great
stuff in the space and and you know
we're um we're kind of partnered with
them to offer that that product through
through our platform and so i think to
me that's like that's such a good entry
point for people because you get to you
get to understand what it is to own and
control
a digital asset um you're not
exposed to the price volatility and uh
like kevin's point you can you know you
can earn interest on it so i think
that's why
that that usdc which is the stablecoin
that sort of application is such a good
such a good entry point for people that
um yeah that that are being kept out of
space and i would be super curious to
also hear
like from uh you know
from from your audience uh around like
what other thing and i don't know if you
if you have this feedback already from
other uh conversations you've had but
like what else is keeping them out of
the space like because i i think one of
the one of the things that i've
discovered from talking to a lot of
potential new users into into crypto and
d5 is um
it really is that there's like there's
so much information like it's too
overwhelming for them to kind of come in
yeah i mean right now especially so many
people we have so much access to
information about their various
different investments and stuff like
that uh and i think it's really just
more or less the volatility and the fact
that most people still to this day
there's a lot more information about
decentralized finance and crypto but
it's still quite unknown um so kevin
you're pretty strong in the world of in
indexing though and i see that uh
wonderful is coming out with a crypto
index essentially so is this going to be
composed of for example some of the top
coins or what can we expect from
something like that
well
that's a product decision i'll let ben
talk about sure i i think that it's
important but i think exposure to just
overall as an investor
many people don't yet know how to get
exposure to the crypto markets i mean i
know there's a lot of excitement out
there but i want to
you know point something out
much of what's going on in crypto is
is happening at the individual level or
at the hedge fund level or the high net
worth level or the family office level
it is not happening yet at the
institutional or pension or sovereign
fund level those those customers that i
i know through my my work in indexing
have told me they there's a great
interest in in allocating the crypto but
no compliance infrastructure that allows
them to do it they have compliance
committees they have compliance
departments they have regulators that
oversee them and so
there's the way to look at this is
it's so nascent it's so early
that if you believe that there's a
future of decentralized finance and
cryptocurrencies which i do you have to
make that binary decision either you
believe it or you don't
there's no in my view it's a personal
opinion i'm not telling people what to
do but i see no reason in my own
personal position what not to get some
exposure while this grinds through the
global
compliance regulator in every geography
and i think over time because of the
the really persuasive uh argument of
reducing fees transparency and speed um
of transactions in just the payment
systems and the global currency markets
there's so much potential i'm a believer
in it so i see no reason not to
participate and it's in terms of using
wonder if i get that exposure i'll let
ben answer that
yeah so i think we look at it just like
you know traditional investors we're
trying to look at it through that lens
so there's you know traditional
investors like you know that that want
to want to be able to buy individual
assets and get exposure and pick and
choose and then there's others that just
want to enter into into a market and get
you know broad exposure through an index
and so that's i think that's a that's a
really important um point and kind of
learning from the traditional markets
that we're taking and then and then kind
of applying in into wonderful there's
there's always going to be people that
just want to you know in one click get
access to the top 10 assets that are
driving a lot of value in the in the in
the d5 space and uh and i think that's
that's also a very good entry point for
for new users um i think for for anyone
that's been in this in the crypto space
during
the last five years or so you'll you
know you'll know that there was a lot of
um a lot of hype around you know
different coins back in 2016 2017
followed by a big crash where really the
only things that survived in a
meaningful way were bitcoin and east and
uh and that's because there's real value
behind those assets you know it's it's
digital gold and it's
programmable smart contracts and so i
think there's a lot of you know
excitement about about crypto and d5
again now and so i think for for people
that are looking to get into space for
the first time
you know the the same principle should
apply it's like where you know where is
their actual value um and and and like
to me that's that's like a really good
place to focus
do you
kevin think that once there is a lot
more regulation and compliance around
this space do you think we'll continue
seeing the same level of volatility in
let's say bitcoin and ether up 30 in a
day down 30 in a day you think that's
something that would continue or would
kind of stabilize out a bit more over
time
no i think these products are innocent
they're very very early i think they'll
they're very very volatile if you're
getting involved in owning uh you know
bitcoin and eth the thing i would point
out though and certainly i i've expanded
uh my holdings a lot uh owning
cryptocurrencies is is beyond just
bitcoin and ethereum there's so many
other projects going on in level one
uh blockchains and level two blockchains
and all kinds of tokens and coins that
are very interesting projects to
specific to different markets and even
the nft market that's emerging i i want
you know much more exposure to that too
and so
volatility will remain and you're very
you know as astute to point that out uh
until this thing becomes more of a
institutional product because
institutions allocate one two three
percent to portfolios and they don't day
trade it that's not their interest they
own you know i'm speculating when i say
this but many of the people i talk to
their institutional owners treat bitcoin
as a property no different than real
estate so they're interested in owning a
building in boston or maybe one or two
percent holding of a bitcoin that they
can find that's mind ethically and mine
sustainably that's another problem that
the industry is facing but i'm sure it
will resolve over time but they're gonna
hold it for the long term and so you
know
my plan and what i plan my strategy with
this is i'm going to disclose my
holdings after i've you know i don't
want to be accused of being somebody
that buys some illiquid coin and
promotes it and you know that's not my
interest in this i'm going to say look
here's what i own and i think by the
time i finish
you know collecting these positions
there'll be about 20 or maybe 25 of them
and and i'm going to be an investor in
these for the various reasons and i hope
it's it creates a dialogue of the pros
and cons of owning these different uh
coins tokens positions blockchains level
ones level twos because i've been
working very hard
in terms of understanding
which of these spaces i want to be a
participant in and so you know people
count call me all the time you're going
to own any dogecoin and all of this
stuff i'm interested in things that have
a very long-term uh digital uh potential
and and that's that's what i'm going to
do and i'm i'm v you know i'm very
interested in being part of the
community and i certainly am now and i'm
a big advocate for this but above all my
number one thing
if there's anything i want to talk to
crypto is i think the real potential is
getting the regulator to regulate it and
i want that to happen because that will
un you know open up the floodgates of
institutional capital that will create
a lot of value for everybody and and
their therein lies the challenge i think
the regulator is doing a great job
obviously at different speeds in
different geographies canada is
different than switzerland different
than britain australia new zealand and
here in the us uh you know
where everybody's debating when this is
going to be regulated and the
regulator's making a lot of um you know
communications about their focus on this
they're going to get it right and
they're the lead regulator globally so
we want them to get it right and
encourage them to do so so i i think
these are very exciting times
so a platform like wonderful that's
going to have a certain amount of coins
available and it will all be regulated
and fully compliant right now i was
looking on coin market cap this morning
there's over 12 000 different projects
that someone can possibly buy you know
yeah it's crazy so
at that point when and if we don't know
right now there will be compliance let's
just speak united states for now
will any of these other coins trading of
that essentially not be tolerated or
allowed and or
any platform that does allow the trading
of those let's say non-regulated coins
will that be something that's tolerated
or how do you see that working
well the way i look at it is a regulated
coin is going to be worth a lot more to
an institutional investor than an
unregulated one so of the universe of 10
000 plus coins if the regulator starts
to regulate for example stable coins and
says this one is compliant and this one
isn't there
that that in itself creates a lot of
value and so i don't see a world five
years from now loaded with unregulated
you know digital tokens and coins
because the demand for those is going to
be a fraction of what the regulated
coins would be and that goes for every
geography the real potential here is to
get global regulators in every market
let's start with asia europe um north
america to say let's just pick one
stable coin and make that a payment
system can you imagine the savings that
we could do in just buying and selling
in different currencies like the swiss
franc the euro and british pound or the
us dollar which i have to do anyways
because i'm an investor in those
countries and i want to own those stocks
in those domestic markets well i get
clipped every time by fx traders on both
sides of the trade very very inefficient
really slow very expensive the potential
of decentralized finance to clean all
that up is so big that that's why i
don't think it's ever going away this is
innovation in technology and financial
services the biggest market in the world
the potential is massive and i just
think what we're waiting for is
regulators to regulate and i'm willing
to wait i because i know
they know the potential is great
for the for this innovation and i think
it's a very exciting time i've said it
before i'll say it again to be an
investor in digital it's a binary
decision either you believe in it or you
don't there's many uh you know skeptics
i totally appreciate that i am not one
of them
okay so for
global compliance then regulation it
really comes down to a stable coin being
accepted in north america as well as
let's say europe these countries
partaking in a single stable coin or it
has to well no like they could be
multiple coins it could be multiple you
know stable coins maybe each country has
its own stable coin i don't know so that
could be a possibility as well yeah i
mean anything's a possibility but the
core theme here is compliance in a
regulatory you know governed by by
regulation because that's the only way
you're going to get institutional money
there are no cowboys you know this
dialogue that's occurred that's the
popular press wants to say that
kryptonians or the founders of
cryptocurrencies want to rate you know
wage a war on regulators and never want
to be regulated that's not true that's
just simply not true the crypto
community wants to work with regulators
so that they can become an institutional
product because that's where the real
capital is and so that's that's really
the challenge and the opportunity in
today's digital markets
excellent so ben right now utilizing
crypto i hold some various different
coins and such but actually using those
on a day-to-day basis is of course not
something that i'm doing not many
companies accept it or anything um is
when do you think
there could be a possibility for this
becoming more of a
used currency
in the day-to-day transactions of most
people and right now transactions for
doing that are also extremely high um so
yeah when do you think we could see an
outlook for that
yeah i think it's gonna take definitely
more adoption for us to get to that
stage where we can see payments on a
day-to-day basis through through crypto
um i think if we again if we rerun
rewind a few years um the expectation
was that bitcoin would be the you know
the new form of payment and obviously
that has that dialogue has changed a lot
i think it's it's pretty pretty
universally accepted now that bitcoin is
a store of value um like kevin said it's
property that you know investors want to
you know want to hold but there are
other kind of assets in the space i
think that provide um you know that have
lower transaction costs or or even
things like lightning network on on top
of bitcoin that that that does bring
down the transaction costs and make it
more realistic to um to use that as a as
sort of a day-to-day payment um but i
think we're gonna need to see
more adoption like i think the the stat
right now is i think around one percent
of
um of of the global population um has
you know owns or holds crypto um so i
think we're going to need to see that uh
number go up significantly um again a
gaining item for that is regulation uh
not just like institutions for sure
which kevin's talked about and then also
you know i think a lot of users you know
retail that we talk to um you know
regulation is something that they see in
headlines all the time right it's like
you know china crackdown sec you know
you know
and and so on and so forth and so i
think that does also keep retail out of
um out of the space not early adopters
like early adopters are in regardless of
what the regulators are saying and
they're you know um
have been in the space for a long time
but i think for for kind of the the next
part of the market segment to come in
you know that uh that the market needs
to mature um quite a bit more and and i
think that's um yeah that's really
through uh like
aside from regulation there's also
education that needs to be done like i
think um it's great like you know people
like you being able to
have a voice and sort of share um like
you know some of the barriers and
opportunities and things like that for
people getting into the space i think
it's i think it's super important so
it's not just uh you know crypto cowboys
that are are saying hey this is the the
future the only way to go it's like
there you know there needs to be a good
kind of informed discussion about it
great how much time do we have left
because i have a couple more questions
i'd like to run by you
kevin
i could do another five minutes okay
awesome uh all
most of my audience is between the age
of 50 um 18 to around 35
and then i do also have some some older
individuals typically speaking as people
get older
they start allocating a bit more of
their portfolio towards fixed income
things of that nature do you think that
moving into towards retirement do you
think that an individual who is let's
say 40 or above right now should wait to
utilize a product like an index and or
maybe even use a high interest account
like that to gain diversity towards
cryptocurrency or should they
potentially even
just
buy coins specifically like bitcoin or
ethereum
well you know the the
the mantra that i've lived by
that's really saved me over the years
through volatile markets is the idea of
diversification everybody defines that
in different ways but my mother taught
me a very basic metric that i've still
used today
i never have more than 20 percent in any
one sector of the economy
and there's 11 sectors including real
estate and i'd like to argue it doesn't
exist yet but over the next decade
cryptocurrencies will become the 12th
sect of the s p it's my own personal
yeah you never have more than 20 anyone
sector and never more than
percent in any one stock or bond so you
know you could apply that to crypto as
well and so
for me uh getting exposure to crypto um
if i'm successful by the brand in our
operating company portfolio get to seven
percent
that will be made up of a large
portfolio of different cryptocurrencies
tokens coins uh level one project uh for
new chains uh level two
just a a really diverse portfolio and as
i mentioned earlier i will disclose that
when it's built uh so i can hopefully we
can have a dialogue with people that are
interested because i'm certainly getting
question every day what i own and i
really did i find distasteful this idea
that uh people you know create these
liquid coins you've talked about 12 000
coins well majority of those are never
heard of and somebody's trying to go
online and promote them um which i just
i just find distasteful i won't i won't
participate in that kind of thing but
the whole the whole binary decision for
anybody that's 18 to 40
if that range of your viewers is to make
that
decision
in the fork in the road the binary
decision am i going to participate in
cryptocurrencies or not yes or no it's a
simple yes or no and if the answer is
yes diversification in my view is what
you want to do you don't want to just on
bitcoin just on ethereum there's many
other ways to do it so it really comes
down to personal preference of well not
preference but idea of if you believe in
the space or not awesome all right and
one last question i had a couple people
ask me uh specifically for this
interview whether or not right now we're
talking about how crypto specifically
bitcoin is like gold 2.0 do you still
view
do you think that gold physical gold
still has any place at a hedge against
inflation when we have options like
crypto
i had a couple people ask me that
yeah and i get asked that every single
day i still have a five percent
weighting in gold and i use i pay for
storage of gold bullion and i also use a
couple of etfs to rebalance the five
percent but you know as i said earlier
crypto will probably
ellipse that in terms of size of
portfolio weighting um because i'm
starting to view crypto as a sector it's
on a personal opinion uh gold is a five
percent weighting is an asset as you
it's not easy to stake gold or make
interest off gold it's just a hedge
against inflation in my view and it's
been around uh since the two you know 2
000 years the romans used to hoard it so
i i have no intention of dumping it it's
just going to remain there um and we're
so early in crypto
but i i i view crypto as a productivity
tool bitcoin is an asset like real
estate but you know level one
blockchains those are productivity tools
i'm going to be working in the watch
industry creating nfts for watches so
that i can have authentication
associated with my watch pieces so
there's so many different use cases for
me it's a very exciting time and i just
want to be an investor in not everything
i'm going to invest is going to work
obviously but i have multiple
investments and i probably spend 60
percent of my day looking at new crypto
or blockchain or smart contract
opportunities uh in just deal flow it's
a it's a it's a it's an incredible time
it's like the dawning of the internet
except in a whole new space that's the
way i view it
if you like that video wait did you see
my next one don't forget to click right
over here and subscribe